what we're recording is a response
basically to some comments that were
posted under the entropy video and so
youtube has a pretty bad reputation in
terms of the quality of its comments
usually and
sometimes you get abusive comments
sometimes you don't get such intelligent
comments but i really don't feel that's
the case for 60 symbols in fact we get
some quite perceptive quite intelligent
quite thought-provoking comments both
positive and negative on the videos and
in particular the entropy video um i've
had a number of emails having a number
of comments posted under the video and
there have been a number of really
important questions raised and i guess
the thing that i'm slightly
uncomfortable about with that with that
video which i felt i could have put
across a lot better
was to really point out the difference
between an analogy and what's actually
going on and so a cardinal rule i used
to teach
for six years i taught a first year
module on thermal kinetic physics where
entropy plays a key role
and my cardinal rule was to make that
distinction when i've given that i
haven't i've disobeyed that card in a
rule in the video i feel a little bit
uncomfortable and people have picked up
on that and quite rightly picked up on
that
so let me state for the record
well there are a couple of things the um
somebody called penguin jin and
somebody called human chemistry 101 have
asked questions about well i've
suggested that what i really didn't put
across was the idea of the sort of
evolution of the history of entropy i
guess what i need to point out um
and it's stated on the 60 symbols
website but maybe i need to reiterate
that is that when we do these videos
they're not meant to be tutorials not
really meant to be lectures they're
meant to be what does that symbol mean
to a particular scientist and if
somebody says entropy to me the first
name that springs into my head is
boltzmann and the first concept that
springs into my head is the connection
of entropy to configurations and
arrangements and that's what you get in
the video but of course having taught
the course for quite some time i am well
aware that there are people like
clausius like carno who really made him
very important contributions to entropy
but for me when i hear entropy boltzmann
springs to mind and
that's the first point so okay i guess i
glossed over to a certain extent of
history the second point i think perhaps
the more important point is so i talk
about in that video about students and
and distributions of students and how
students are moving around and how the
entropy of those students changes
and we could think of for example with
the students here who are milled about
the milling about they're filling out
this space quite well we could think
about bringing those into what we term a
low entropy state where we pack them all
nicely together nicely ordered in the
center of this this this lovely grain
and then as they sort of
uh
spread out move away from that nice
other state we say we're moving to a
higher entropy state and that's really
what entropy is about it's about this
dispersal of energy about this moving
from
a state where
everything's nicely packed and nicely
tightly ordered into one where
everything spreads out and you can apply
that to gas molecules just as easy as
you can apply to students
the difficulty is you have to i what i
didn't make a hundred percent clear and
what i spent so much time doing in my
lectures which is why it's so
frustrating is that this is a this is an
analogy
when i talk about those students i'm
really thinking in my head of gas
molecules moving around and these
concepts of entropy apply to gas
molecules we can't
say that a particular arrangement of
students has a thermodynamic entropy but
a particular arrangement of gas
molecules does
and the as those gas molecules spread
out as they disperse that that that's
really the essence of entropy but for
example time and time again you'll see
entropy just got discussed in terms of
well
if i have a nice ordered system
oh let's let's let's use some cards if i
have some nice orderly system where
these cards are lined
up
all the same and all in the same sort of
state
that for example if there's a
after some time they do that well this
is an example of entropy it's an example
of of disorder increasing but that
applies to gas molecules it doesn't
apply to real world objects like this
there is no difference in the
thermodynamic entropy
or entropy of that particular
arrangement compared to that particular
arrangement where the entropy has
changed is in terms of when i do work
when i move these around in my muscles
that's where the entropy is and so
having spent so much time during my
undergraduate lectures trying to put
across this this this
very important distinction between an
analogy and what's actually happening
i was a little bit gutted to um to to to
to find that i hadn't really put across
that um
that so well in the in the video and
entropy and um the final thing i guess
is
people have picked up on well you
you you should have covered the the the
arrow of time you should have covered
how entry people is a second into this
law we can't these are five minute
videos and of 10 minute videos and what
we're trying to do is really as i said
try to put across the essence of what
these things mean to us
what brady particularly with me spends
most of his time doing
is editing out
i might talk for an hour and then i put
brady in the horrible position of well
what what do i use here and um
so
i
what i'm delighted to see is that the
entropy video has generated so much
discussion and debate and that's really
what i'm doing this for to to have that
debate in discussion and to have people
even when i'm delighted about that
but
i um would have preferred i guess if i
had discussed things and described
things in a slightly different manner so
you you do read all your comments and
look at them absolutely yeah it's um it
can be eye-opening and it's just like
with undergraduate lectures you we get
questionnaires and
you know those questionnaires the very
vast majority okay you get some strange
and silly comments like there should be
more beer in lectures but the vast
majority of those are very mature even
from first-year students very mature
very important comments that feed back
in and guide my teaching and i sort of
see these youtube videos it's a real
learning experience for me and um
particularly trying i find it extremely
difficult to compress an hour down into
10 minutes really really really
difficult
and yeah so those comments are really
useful
you